complete shock and sadness over the loss
of the beloved comedian tv host and
america's dad bob saget welcome to
entertainment tonight you know there
really has been a collective outpouring
of grief and also tons of love for bob
from his co-stars and comedy legends as
we learn new details surrounding bob's
passing and a life gone too soon
i've got to live forever i've got three
daughters and a wife and a life i i
can't die if god forbid this kind of
thing god forbid this kind of thing
should happen do you love me
we have an unresponsive guest and a room
there's no pulse that's the 9-1-1 call
placed yesterday around 4 p.m bob's body
was found in his hotel room by security
at this ritz carlton in orlando florida
sheriffs tell e.t there were no signs of
foul play or drug use the medical
examiner's office performed an autopsy
today cause of death is being
investigated
[Music]
the 65 year old passed away doing what
he loved stand up this is the last known
video of him performing a two-hour set
the night before in jacksonville an
audience member there tells e.t he was
very happy and had high energy he was
testing out different jokes and seeing
how his comedy resonated with the crowd
you guys are awesome
he seemed in great health and he seemed
really happy with the persona that he
was creating on stage in the different
delivery
tim wilkins was bob's opening act and
revealed to et bob was working on an
upcoming special he was really excited
and really was in a perfect spot in his
private life his business life he was
just happy
i'm really in shock it's very very
difficult 65 is not old at all the
comedy community in mourning from
margaret cho to longtime friend gilbert
gottfried you spoke with him just a few
days ago um what was his mood like he
was his typical self
you know always very sarcastic he was
excited to go back on the road he was
looking forward to just traveling and
meeting his audience
when you care about somebody
especially now i'm finding you got to
let them know you got to reach out in
our last interview november 2020 the dad
of three girls spoke about making sure
his family knew they are loved it's nice
to get that
heart emoji back sometimes texting is a
gift not a curse
34 year old daughter aubry shared what
appears to be his last text to her thank
you love you showtime the family tells
e.t we are devastated
even though he's got a couple years on
me i'm like usually the adult in the
relationship you know bob leaves behind
wife of three years kelly rizzo the 42
year old travel blogger had just posted
video of their best moments from 2021.
we met her just before their 2018
wedding and they were already talking
like each other he's just the most pure
heart ever and she's very pure of heart
and i can't believe anyone understands
me
the couple actually first met on
instagram in 2015 bob center this dm he
said hey wanna come to a show of mine
and then go out for some burgers and
lobsters and then i was like okay we can
be friends and then i was like oh no i
kind of like him and then we got married
this happened really natural
and and her family apparently adores me
and my daughters adore her this is a
wonderful wonderful time in both of our
lives
[Music]
as for bob's full house family a gutted
john stamos joined his castmates in
paying tribute to their beloved
patriarch quote i am broken i will never
have another friend like him i keep
thinking the pain is going to go away
but
it doesn't you don't have to go through
this alone
a devastated lori lachlan tells e.t
quote i will miss his kind heart and
quick wit the most genuine heart i've
known in my life candace cameron beret
tweeted i loved him so much 35 years
wasn't long enough hello that sentiment
shared by jody sweden quote
you were supposed to be here longer
how rude
how rude
mary kate and ashley olsen tell e.t they
quote know that he will continue to
guide us as he always has dave coulier
simply states i'll never let go brother
love you this is the thing that touches
me the most
they're friends of mine
they are
really friends of mine bob and dave were
actually best friends long before full
house dave collier who lived in my house
when i moved out to l.a because he had
no place else to stay it's a true story
i've known him since i was 18 years old
suzanne you learned about bob's death in
a very unsettling way bob saget has died
at the age of 65 suzanne this is a this
is a shocking loss and i'm hearing it
from you well i was on the today show in
australia i was hoping my jaw didn't
drop suzanne summers filmed step by step
next door to full house and even
appeared in an episode do you mind if i
use the phone my flip phone died they
would call me at lunch can you come over
and just show up in a scene and so i
would do that so what should we all
remember about bob well it's a lot more
than his good looks it's um
there are people who come along once in
a lifetime and he's one of those he will
be very very missed i'm really thrilled
that i and honored that i got to know
him i always felt the same way about
john ritter gone too soon is all i could
say it reminded me when i got the news
that john ritter had died also a friend
also a shock
tom bergeron who took over hosting
duties after bob on afv recalled a
poignant act of friendship
helping me button my
15 years as host of afe by showing up
uh for that final um that final episode
well the fun is just beginning my friend
what did that mean to you meant the
world to me has been really good good
good person on the 30th anniversary of
afe there was an anniversary special and
alfonso
and bob and i showed up the three of us
on that day you would have thought we
were brothers from another mother and it
was just it was great to hang out and
share stories
john mayer who performed at bob's 2018
wedding honored his friends saying quote
i will never forget you and i hope i get
to see you in my dreams
fellow comic pete davidson revealed bob
was there for him when dealing with
mental health struggles quote he stayed
on the phone with my mom for hours
trying to help and make sure i was okay
people are really they're they're
talking about the bob who supported
every comedian out there you could tell
every all the comedians are coming out
and talking about bob
terrible loss
i was just on his podcast this was a
little less than a week ago
what do you remember about that last
that conversation i just remember bob's
enthusiasm for comedy itself with bob
you got everything you got this
incredibly dirty comedy and then this
incredibly wholesome side as much as we
loved him and danny tanner and the host
of america's funniest videos the
filthiest mouth in the world
nobody blewer nobody nastier yes bob's
image as america's dad was vastly
different from his stand-up routines
that made him beloved to fellow
comedians like george wallace who knew
bob for over 40 years the guy could not
talk anybody he was the type guy that
you could talk to once every three
months okay you pick up on the same
conversation where you live there's no
way you'll learn it and i wrote it and
it's offensive here it is
oh
i'll say something to my friends about
it which is not meant in any harmful way
and then you would not say it on stage i
try to tread a middle ground and hope
for the best
comedy clubs around the nation paid
tribute to him today including the
legendary comedy store in l.a where bob
was a regular early in his career i was
just working here trying to get jokes
trying to be funny
that's jim carrey often said he was
sabotaging one of my interviews before
and he tries to do whatever he can we
all know each other it's like we all did
the same thing together except jim he's
an all-day comedian jim really tried to
hurt me
bob's pals took turns lampooning him at
his 2008 comedy central roast what do
you remember about that night i remember
that was a lot of fun
uh it was outrageous i googled bob saget
and it came back why
they wanted at the end for the olsen
twins to come out and both given the
they said no to it
he was very protective of the olds and
twins because
he knew them since they were babies he
saw himself as their father
dying is easy comedy is hard interviews
are in the middle
if you know bob you can't help but to
laugh and it's going to happen to all of
us and i guarantee you right now he said
if you want to do me a favor you keep
laughing god bless entertainment tonight
[Music]